it is 1018 am
I think it's Saturday or Sunday
it's Saturday May 18th in about 40
minutes I'll be playing ezra chambers
who's FM I'll be black so this will be a
pretty quick prop session because I'll
have to start walking over to the club
in maybe 20 30 minutes
so I began prepping a little I don't
know what what entirely to expect if we
go to just the Explorer I know it's a
Stockholm County I know some of his like
recent tournament games let me go and
search him real quick chambers the
problem is that he plays a lot of
different things okay I know to expect
you for wait a minute
I clicked the wrong thing the pair
against white yeah so I know to expect a
four I'm planning to play e5 most likely
Knight f3 and then he's played all these
moves I mean Knight c3 Knight f6 he's
played all these different things so I
mean he could play a Spanish - I was
looking at his chest con games Spanish
is most likely so let's go back to chest
base and let's take a look at some stuff
yeah so Bishop b5 let's do a quick
review in this line castle castle d3 86
Bishop g5 97 this is playable I think
takes takes Knight H for his main line I
usually play Knight g6 here
now that c6 don't leave stock fish
running
okay let's just look at the main line c6
Bishop c4 d5 right away should be three
and then Knight g6 wait how does that
work my g6 oh because I can take on c3
interesting no no five
so a 5k threatening Bishop takes c3 and
a four so let's say Y plays a four takes
takes ninety seven and this looks very
comfortable for luck okay I'm not going
to spend too much time on any given
variation I just wanted to kind of an
overview of my e4 e5 repper tour so that
was four nights you can play d4 here I
don't think I was too scared of d4 it's
also looking at a three a three take
stick so let's look at this line he
could be potentially tricky she
surprised there's not more games here
I mean I'm pretty sure this is just
equal a queen g6 okay let's look at f/64
ship g4 I've never seen before I take
c3b takes c3 Bishop e6 well this looks
interesting Queen d7 so so I defend I
take and then I gamma the pawn takes and
then casting Queen side wow that's
fascinating I like it
odds are white won't take in Queen d3 we
take it's kind of just equal but at
least it's slightly imbalanced bit ahead
and developments okay fair enough let's
go back I want to look at Spanish
because I mean this is maybe the most
challenging variation out of everything
there's a lot of options that you can
play here so let's go to opening
explorer yeah so Bishop e5 just follow
his games yeah all main line wait has he
played d3 at all he's played d3 3 times
so d3 is unreal I should look at
all right so b5
wait let's start with rookie one more
likely be five here I'll play on
Marshall move order because he plays
anti Marshall he's played a form mostly
I think there is a game um search
Oxshott Chandra Fabiano a car loan from
the US Championships the last game of
the 2016 US Championships or Fabiano one
Oh
slightly different slightly different
but maybe it'll transpose yeah this
should transpose so before you play D
for once also a five all right let's go
back to chat space so rookie 1v5 here
here here so before so if he plays teeth
for this [ __ ] transposed to the car
wanna game after which a shot took just
put in the few moves of this game could
even be here in the database was 92 nice
move Bishop c5 I'm just trying to
understand this position h6 prophylaxis
well if Knight c4 immediately
oh you win the pond okay so lights a
little bit tied down if I should went to
be seven I like this the setup for black
queen depends upon in a six very smooth
that was some very nice positional play
I feel like the way Caruana played it
requires a lot of experience to know
where the pieces should be placed like
starting with Bishop c5 there should be
seven Queen b6 okay and if you plays a
five here
remember there's some Aronian like
marshall gambit type game like d5 here
which maybe i would go into because i
don't think he would be super prepared
yeah D five here an idea is have stock
fish running caronian pata my have
probably so ticks Oh II for oh yeah this
game take sticks and it's just such a
messy position this imagine Queen takes
off three Bishop g4 and black cuts
compensation Queen III rookie it would
be nice
also calamari applied d3 6g - ah yeah
this rook b8 rook b5 idea it's really
interesting
well 98 I'm crazy chess Bishop e6 may be
more intuitive but what happens after
takes oh that files open and then rugby
fives still coming interesting
district takes a six bishop d5 haha
ninety-two okay looks playable c6 is a
week okay I'm running short on time
there's one more game I want to look at
I think it was you Fon Chuck so here we
find Chuck oops
or was it yeah you didn't Yvonne she was
he so Spanish yeah that told you so
with h3 so actually let's go back to
Explorer because I want to see his games
with h3 should be seven
oh he played d3 d5 okay I take six six
okay d3 okay this is not relevant it's
black plays d5 let's go back to chest
base so yeah this is another anti
Marshall variation d3 d5 takes takes 92
what's the point if takes takes takes
Queen d6 rook e1 interesting you see
five is interesting
some nice conversation but definitely a
fight
rook AE 800 no no but okay there's some
transpositions Rick 88 94
yeah that seems nice I need a visa for
f5 or both
okay I'd be fine with that
so Yvonne should play 92 here and then
amazing move Queen d7 ticks ticks
okay let's copy this game yeah such an
amazing game Knight f4 and then they
takes g2 with idea of a five double idea
and if you leave the computer running
for long enough
I think White's just lost not likely
he'll go into this but it's useful to
review be be somewhat inspired so
anything else to look at
look at actually don't know a three I
was looking at this line there should be
five takes Queen e2 Queen d6 what
happens after it takes 95 I know there's
a trap here like takes takes 95 I can't
take on or can I take on d4 oh no I
can't take on d4 because Queen h5 works
for White Queen e6 it's a point of
Queenie six just develop the bishop
and if takes okay a BTech c6 that
actually comes I have to be careful here
long as you can't trust the initial
evaluation of stockfish gasoline
castling trying to judge the position -
I mean this looks pleasant for luck like
nice pawns potential pawn storm ok and
Scotch again how can you trick me in
this line you played c3 what if he
castles here I just t6 huh
so usually play Knight f6 but d6
actually looks very logical c3 Bishop g4
hmm Queen b3 so this is some line Wow
I've never studied this before this is
crazy
takes somehow good for a black I guess
95 looks attractive
computer doesn't like it because he
takes and defends upon soon Isaac's also
natural yeah I would be okay with this
like White's King is probably weaker
than blacks King one more variation
Spanish with d3 so Bishop b5 oops
there should be five right away so in
this position d3 cuz I had a game in
this not too long ago and what happened
I just want some simple line to play I'm
looking at his Explorer so t3 b5
okay let's look at this game Oh a three
very tricky so d6 a3 castling Knight c3
I mean probably the best approach is
just to stick with me line in 95 was
played in this game and Bishop g4 fh3 oh
then I taken my d4 okay so Bishop e3
probably it's still 94 o 94 it takes
takes my d5 and c5 huh actually looks
fine I mean a little bit double-edged
stock pushes beginning to like whites 97
don't know how much I can trust sock
fish but let's play through the line
Knight d7 still ideas later playing c5
and what is this position so we just
trade everything c5 immediately so what
what's the point of rook a c8 a
four-night see I don't understand oh
that's so Bishop d5 it doesn't hit the
rook
I guess interesting
okay so Brooke a v8 possible okay I'll
be a fights alright um I'm ending it
here I have to go and get to the game
thanks guys for watching again I'll
leave links on the in the video
description hope you guys enjoyed this
if you have any questions comment below
and I'll see you in the next video
goodbye